dear friends hope you guys are doing
well
uh as you guys know the recent attacks
that took place in london
uh also uh in uh syria
and there's been attacks all over the
place all over the world really yeah
and these are always costing the lives
of innocent human beings
as usual by extremist groups whoever
they are whichever group they belong to
extremism is extremism yeah there is no
extremism doesn't belong to a religion
that's point number one
and that's what we need to understand
and um a lot of opportunistic people
uh who love to jump hey look this is
what islam teaches this that
one thing i really want to mention is
this if we can equate
islam to terrorism based on 0.0009
of the population of muslims in the
world and we can say that's terrorism
and islam is responsible
why don't we do the opposite why don't
we say okay all right all right
let's use mathematics here if we're
going to use 0.009 percent of muslims to
equate that islam teaches terrorism
then why don't we say okay 99.
99.999 or shall i say 99.0001
of the muslims don't indulge in these
activities and this extremism
so if that's the case then we have more
of a right to equate islam with peace
and mercy rather than terrorism because
the proportion of muslims
99 of muslims do are not involved in
these acts
if one percent less than one percent
are we have more of a right of equating
the standards of mercy
and peace rather than the other way
around that's point number one
now point number two this attacks taking
place you have extremist individuals
like tommy robinson he's an extremist
i don't see anything different between
him
and then extremists like for example
yes may allah guide tony robbins of both
of them yeah they're both
extremist individuals who think extreme
and their actions and behavior and the
things that they say
cause extremist behavior and uh cause a
reaction
of other individuals doing uh extreme
things
like tommy robinson i can say him and
britain first
yeah these guys at britain first are
responsible responsible for the attacks
of joe cox
yeah a female a person
who was butchered in daylight broad
daylight yes
she was killed why because of such
individuals like tommy robinson
and britain first yes not only that
a couple of months ago a man was
attacked in waltham forest
um or for a skate i can't remember in
the train station yeah
and this guy's shouting saying i want
muslim blood i want to kill a muslim
who is responsible for this who do you
think is responsible let's be consistent
who is responsible
for this britain first edl tommy
robinson
simple as the attacks that took place
yesterday
who is responsible for this extremist
groups
do you see that now a common person i
want you guys to share this with normals
and friends
yeah if you guys are watching this as a
non-muslim me and you have a lot in
common yeah
because there's a barrier there's a line
between me and you
and tommy robinson and abu halim i don't
know if you guys know this extremist
groups yeah who happen to be muslims
just like
the uh tommy robinson and individuals
who happen to be british
english fascists far-right groups right
what we're trying to say
is that me and you you have a job
probably nine to five
i have a nine-to-five job you have goals
in life i have goals in life you like
going on holiday i like going on holiday
you go to the pub on friday night i
don't go problem friday night however i
might go play snooker
or or i might go and see my friends
go have ice cream go for a lunch go for
a drive whatever it may be
yes we have fun maybe in a different way
yes i'm an orthodox muslim yeah
i believe to be an orthodox muslim and
i'm telling you that
i from whatever and i'm a reaver from
looking into the religion
i have not come across anything that
tells me
as a muslim to go out there and kill
innocent people
it's absolute rubbish and one other
thing you know what's really funny is
that this picture going off
uh about this sister in hijab walking
past
and these bloody like
these extremist groups that like to
blame
everything on whatever happens you know
if you have a bad apple
you blame all the apples in the world
yeah a sister walking past distraught
you can see it from my face but
after blur her face out um that she's
upset
saying oh look this hijabi girl she
doesn't care more look look
look what what does that mean you know
look what it shows you you know
how stupid can you get how [ __ ]
there's another picture of a white
caucasian man walking by so what are you
going to say oh look at this guy he
doesn't care he must be
he must have some kind of affiliation
with isis probably he was reporting
on his phone or something so silly some
ridiculous theme and seriously
and this is how desperate they are just
to brainwash people just to make them
feel like islam is this threat
nowhere in islam and i challenge anybody
anyone
yes all these bigots sending these haze
and saying this that and there's a
channel called something t tv with the
same nonsense yeah
uh come in and say oh it's that i
challenge you guys and tony robinson
yeah send this video
a place in the quran and the sunnah that
tells us
directly to kill innocent men women
children babies animals i challenge an
open challenge
in the quran that tells us ordinary
muslims to go out there and kill
innocent people i
dare you i challenge you to do that now
this is what tommy robinson had to say
let's have a look at that he gives show
cowardice
okay you're very quick to label this as
a
head is not my foreign my head is not my
ass
this is an islamic jihad attack the man
that done this would have either been
radicalized in a prison
or he would have been radicalized on the
streets of the uk with full knowledge of
our government and our security services
you see
how opportunistic they are and the media
does this yes because it sells yeah
hey look there you go this is why
scientists
please kindly be quiet it's rubbish
you are the same individual that's
promoting
exactly what these guys do you have that
in common
you have that in common you both are
doing the same thing those guys are
preaching hate yes yes kill
kill innocent uh um non-muslims yeah and
you're doing the same thing
look what they're doing we need to
attack back we take our country blood
but all these rubbish and nonsense what
the where the
what kind of paranormal activity are you
watching yeah so you're doing the exact
same you guys have that in common
me us ordinary muslims yes even on
orthodox
we have something in common with the
british public yeah we go about our own
life
yeah we're just like look you believe
that i believe this you do your thing i
do my thing
simple as not this rubbish we're going
to kill you this this nonsense
and you have something in common with
extremist group you're both extreme
you're you both have the mentality you
and
isis tommy robinson you and britain
first and isis have the same mentality
you both think islam is about extremism
yes islam is about terrorism you both
have something in common
you both are extreme in your views yes
you
cherry-pick and blame why don't you
tommy robinson talk about
joe cox's murder yes the man who got
attacked
um in a train station yeah the the
muslim man who stabbed
the mosque there was a plan on uh
bombing a mosque
who are responsible for this who are
responsible was it a muslim muslim
muslim
no no no muslim world war one muslim
world war two muslim hiroshima muslim
negra
muslim yeah um stunning killing millions
of people muslim
mao zedong and millions of people was a
muslim yes
so it's please so what you're saying cut
the rubbish and if you look at
statistics and like i said before
we hate any kind of violence done
against any innocent person yeah
that police officer those innocent
people on that road
what did they do to deserve this what
did they do
nothing that guys were going about their
business that could have been me on the
road
when that man drove that on the road on
that pavement
do you really think he was driving
thinking hmm hey oh there's a muslim
then let me avoid them
no the guy is a maniac he the same
person is running them over is probably
thinking
that we muslims were hypocrites he was
us dead
so do you see there's something in
common with these individuals
they all think the same that's the
reason why these
far-right groups yeah they go and kill
joe
joe
cox a non-muslim yes because why
they want anyone they think they're all
the same yes
same as this extremist group they think
we muslims are washed out they were the
same
as the non-muslims same with far-right
groups yeah they kill
non-muslims and they want to attack
muslims same thing guys look at the
pattern
exactly the same thing this is exactly
the same thing so
this is what i want to say and now one
thing i want to say for like the media
as you guys know crimes happen
knife attacks are happening you have
more of a chance
of dying by falling off a ladder
or your kit this is study that shows
yeah your own appliances on your
in your house can cause you death more
likely
then you can die more likely of a car
accident yes
you are more likely to die of a
gang-related accident yes
no accident incident yes then of a
terrorist attack yes
okay now we'll condemn all of them what
we're just trying to say is why is
one given such a big light like boom
but when it's knife crime or for example
when somebody
a group of thugs attack the police why
isn't it like
why isn't the media there you know why
is that this ma
burst of outcry you know so this is what
you're saying it's just like hypocrisy
you know
if you look at statistics it clearly
shows i'm going to put some links at the
description box in the uh below have a
look for yourself read it for yourself
it's an absolute joke
absolute joke in america out of 330 days
355 mass shootings
mass shooting am i going to go and say
hey look that's uh all caucasian
or white yeah let's be careful to white
people when you go to the cinema no come
on be
real guys so what i'm just trying to say
is share this with your non-muslim
friends
and also we did interview uh the public
we actually had
just one interview um we wouldn't really
have time due to some circumstances
let's just see what they said and how
they felt like affected by it let's
quickly watch that
hi guys uh my name is ali uh what's your
name jonas jonas and tom
tom you're from bryan yeah norway you're
from norway okay
um obviously you guys know what happened
don't let's go into it how do you feel
like regarding the attacks that happened
how do you feel in general and how do
you feel towards
muslims um i don't feel any different
towards muslims
i feel uh i feel scared i guess i was at
westminster bridge two days ago yeah so
it like
it could have been me type thing it's
obviously a sad day
it's a weird atmosphere in london yeah
yeah
uh but yeah there's nothing wrong with
this okay what about you
honestly
it's sad it makes me sad but um
as you can see not everybody is that
tony robinson yeah we should all accept
that yeah
you have lovely individuals like those
individuals who we interviewed who
clearly said
that look this has got nothing to do
with that you know
that they don't feel different about
muslims and this is how it should be
yeah so hope you guys enjoyed it share
this with tommy robinson
britain first yes please share it with
them send it to them
so they can know that there is a line
between us
the british public and these extremist
groups
like abuhalima like isis like tommy
robinson that britain first
they're all in the same boat they're all
in the same boat there's no difference
between them no yeah we have a barrier
between us
and like i said before innocent people
are being killed all over the world
all over the world and we should condemn
all of them we should not be selected
human
life doesn't have a price this is it's
not hey this one is more valuable
than the other so guys hope you hope you
enjoyed it share with your friends and
family assalamualaikum